bonjour madame
disponible et de venir nous exposer ce
qui s'est passé cet hiver où nous en
sommes par rapport à ce phénomène
érosion côtière on a eu un recul de 35
mètres entre Novembre et actuellement
d'érosion côtières de submersion voilà
bienvenue sur le Bassin d'Arcachon
la côte atlantique attire toujours et
pourtant l'océan on l'a fait rétrécir un
peu plus chaque année le trait de côte
cette limite tout s'arrête les vagues à
marée haute reculent le phénomène n'est
pas nouveau mais il s'amplifie avec la
montée des eaux à quelques kilomètres
d'Arcachon cette plage a été avalée par
les vagues
380 mètres de moins en 50 ans
[Musique]
Cédric gère la forêt et la dune depuis
10 ans il observe la plage ce
métamorphoser on a eu cet hiver donc il
y a eu 35 mètres de recul et on a quand
même eu sur un coup de mer 12 mètres de
recul en une nuit
vraiment vraiment très vite
la marée qui monte et donc il vient
taper vraiment sur le bas de Dune on
voit bien aussi là les fritesment de la
dune avec des restes de tronc qui sont
en train de tomber avec les racines qui
sont à la complètement la complètement
nue tout à fait donc là dans ces travaux
là pour nous l'idée c'est aussi de
d'éviter que les arbres tombent sur la
plage donc on exploite la forêt sur ces
bordures là
alors ce qu'il en reste bien sûr c'était
touché par l'incendie il restait une
petite partie donc on est obligé de les
retirer pour pas qu'il tombe sur la page
le site est très prisé pour protéger les
promeneurs quoi qu'il en coûte plus d'un
million d'euros ont été mis sur la table
cette année par la collectivité et la
facture continue de grimper chaque année
qu'est-ce que l'on attend de nos élus
c'est une aide sur la partie
réglementaire parce que on le voit ici
on est sur un site qui évolue très
rapidement du fait du phénomène
d'estuaire des passes du bassin ça
recule très vite on doit s'adapter mais
d'un point de vue réglementaire c'est
beaucoup plus lent parce que pour faire
une reconstruction c'est au minimum deux
ans de réflexion et nous c'est en hiver
l'intervention alors si on attend deux
hivers le pot on ne le déplace pas il
est à l'eau voilà donc c'est de pouvoir
trouver des moyens de s'adapter sur des
choses vraiment très très particuliers
ce qu'on peut apporter nous en tant que
législateur c'est des outils aux élus
locaux pour leur faciliter la vie et
pour voilà avoir des moyens
effectivement plus souples d'adaptation
de nos territoires en tout cas c'est
l'objectif du travail que je vais mener
pendant cette année
la députée entame une année bien
particulière
[Musique]
Sophie panona qui a été nommé par le
gouvernement présidente de la commission
du trait de côte
[Musique]
la députée va sillonner toute la France
pour trouver des réponses à toutes ces
questions
on continue à protéger on protège
davantage comment on s'adapte on
relocalise comment
on aperçoit donc les fameux Pérets qui
protègent
de l'érosion qui protège de la montée de
l'eau également pour l'instant en tout
cas à marée haute l'eau s'approche quasi
à certains endroits il n'y a plus du
tout de place
au bord des protections en béton
le long du littoral fleuri ses ouvrages
car pour continuer à vivre en bord de
mer les propriétaires doivent se
protéger ce sont leurs terrains c'est
donc à eux de payer pour défendre leur
villa et on voit les dans l'entretien se
fait en direct d'ailleurs on voit les
grues les camions les pelles plutôt les
pelles pardon en train de d'apporter du
gravats
pour garder sa maison avec vue sur
l'océan un homme s'est lancé dans un
projet pharaonique
[Musique]
cette digue de 450 mètres de long haute
de 30 mètres
cela fait 35 ans que Benoît bartheroth
n'a qu'une seule obsession protégée son
coin de paradis
on doit pas attendre que l'État vienne
vous aider ou que non la défense du
trait de côte ici elle est 100% privée
donc vous pouvez pas appeler au secours
exactement alors là ça a pas l'air voyez
ça a pas l'air mais on a versé plus de
450 camions depuis le 23 décembre vous
le voyez pas mais il y a un pied à pied
très large qui est la fondation qui est
le fameux chaînage
après on en met du petit comme ça les
vagues prennent le petit le mettre
dedans d'accord et ça fait un truc
souple et armé et comme vous le voyez il
a digue cette partie j'ai commencé cette
partie depuis le pavillon que vous voyez
là-bas j'ai commencé depuis janvier 94
c'est allongement ça a pas bougé
si Benoît bartheroth n'avait pas
déboursé des millions d'euros sa maison
aurait déjà été engloutie
une permanente et il le sait si l'océan
gagne il perdra tout sans aucune
indemnisation par l'État
alors faut-il faire évoluer la loi
comment l'État doit-il accompagner les
propriétaires
le 3 février dernier en Gironde un
immeuble devient le symbole de l'érosion
à seulement 20 mètres de l'océan il est
démoli
il y a en fonction de ce que sera la
réalité du réchauffement climatique
jusqu'à 50 000 habitations logement
jusqu'à
750 entreprises qui vont être concernées
à un titre ou un autre des dizaines de
kilomètres d'infrastructures qui vont
être d'ici la fin de ce siècle
concernés par cette érosion du trait de
côte après une longue bataille
judiciaire les 78 propriétaires évacués
de leur appartement sont
exceptionnellement indemnisés coût pour
l'État 7 millions d'euros
mais comment les habitants peuvent-ils
concrètement s'adapter à ce trait de
côte la relocalisation est-elle possible
partout sur le territoire au Cap Ferret
la députée retrouve le maire et se
restaurateur installé ici depuis trois
générations le Cap Ferret fait 4 km de
long sur 1 km et demi large ou est-ce
qu'on va nous réaliser nous relocaliser
à Saucats ça Belin-Béliet moi j'aime
bien voir l'eau depuis le matin on en a
parlé avec Monsieur le Maire il y a des
territoires où effectivement on pourra
relocaliser parce qu'on aura alphoncier
dispo parce que ça peut être
envisageable ici sur cette presqu'île du
Cap Ferret c'est pas c'est pas le sujet
on est sur effectivement
la protection construction de digue
d'enrichissement quelle protection vous
mettez en place
immédiat aujourd'hui
[Musique]
trouver une stratégie et vite la députée
garde en esprit les prévisions des
scientifiques d'après eux d'ici 2100 le
niveau des mers aura augmenté de plus
d'un mètre l'eau pénétrer dans les
terres un million et demi d'habitants en
France pourrait être impactés une
nouvelle carte pourrait se dessiner en
bleu ces zones auront disparues la
circonscription de Sophie panonacle aura
rétréci
pour certains la relocalisation semble
inévitable la députée a rendez-vous au
flot bleu le célèbre camping se trouve
juste derrière la dune du Pilat qui
s’érode doucement
après les incendies c'est le sable qui
grignote le lieu le gérant a décidé de
laisser faire la nature
et nous on s'aperçoit que
la dune glisse vers nous mouvement on le
voit bien là on voit les arbres on a
l'impression que il pousse sur la dune
ça veut dire que tout se sable a avancé
et là vous avez perdu combien de est-ce
que vous vous arrivez à évaluer combien
de mètres en combien d'années
faut savoir que
centaines de mètres derrière sous la
dune il y a une piscine
sanitaire en fait il y a le double du
camping de l'autre côté voilà peut-être
qu'un jour il y aura paraîtra je sais
pas il s'est posé la question de savoir
s'il fallait réinstaller les camping ici
ou si on profitait de ce phénomène
dramatique pour les installer plus en
rétro littoral
mais bon
on peut bien imaginer que dans tous les
cas un jour il faudra le faire digérer
l'incendie après avoir digéré le covid
digérer l'incendie et après
une dizaine d'années on parlera du reste
on a un peu de temps encore devant nous
donc voilà moi je suis très attaché à la
dune parce que j'y suis tous les jours
donc après voilà après aller ailleurs je
sais pas on verra
faudra-t-il déplacer les campings ou les
réorganiser
aujourd'hui 600 d'entre eux sont menacés
par l'érosion et les outils juridiques
manquent
cet après-midi là Sophie panona cl le
réunit les élus du bassin d'Arcachon je
voudrais vraiment en fait vous entendre
vos réactions vos remarques vos attentes
par rapport à ces travaux votre
expertise en tout cas de territoires il
s'agit de relocaliser me tourne vers les
services de l'État qu'est-ce qui est
aujourd'hui nous est autorisé ont permis
comment on travaille ensemble pour
trouver ces zones de relations
d'avoir des réponses un petit peu
tranchées de l'État qui nous permettent
effectivement d'expliquer aux gens nos
décisions ou effectivement des
impératifs qui nous sont qui nous sont
imposés aujourd'hui on est sur des
travaux à 5 ans et à 30 ans ça veut dire
que l'urgence elle est absolue et elle
est maintenant il y a bien une solution
envisagée par la députée la création
d'un fond d'érosion une taxe
additionnelle de
0,01% sur les frais de notaire une sorte
de cagnotte à laquelle tous les Français
participeraient à l'achat d'un bien
immobilier pour venir en aide aux élus
du littoral la proposition si elle est
retenue pourrait être discutée dans le
projet de loi de finances 2024
d'ici là Sophie panonacle continue son
tour de France de la mer en quête de
solution
[Musique]